[Musique]
maintenant depuis déjà un certain nombre
d'années on fait du whisky en France du
whisky français euh avec une une vraie
intention de territorialité euh donc
c'est vrai rechercher rechercher
l'intérêt du terroir rechercher une
typicité euh et pas forcément euh bah
faire du copier-collé de whisky
irlandais ou équossis on va de toute
façon se se se se contonner au principe
de ce qui fait du wiussi c'est-à-dire de
distyer de l'alcool de Malte euh de le
faire vieillir pendant minimum 3 ans
mais le reste finalement et bien on va
essayer de de d'apporter une touche
supplémentaire de qui se rapporte à
notre terroir à nos idées à nos
convictions et ce qui permet vraiment
d'avoir de commencer avoir une une vraie
identité de whisky français c'est du mal
de d'orge de poitoucharante euh qui est
malté ench maritime donc c'est on a une
malterie tout près et qui nous permet
vraiment de travailler en local j'ai eu
des retours
d'Américains amateur de whisky et même
de de de personnes
amatrices de whisky qui qui faisait très
régulièrement des visites de de
distillerie écossaise et j'ai eu plutôt
de très bons de très bons retour euh B
sur ce produit qui même s'il est encore
un peu jeune puisque euh bah notre
premier whisky effectivement N a que 3
ans le travail qui a été fait justement
avec ce fu Pino apporte quelque chose de
voilà vraiment très intéressant produit
également des jeans et des spiritueux la
gamme de jeans est de quatre pour
l'instant donc il en a quatre jeans
qu'on essaie d'être aussi encore une
fois très très typique et très local
donc don le plus emblématique est un
jean à la pousse d'épinees un peu plus
une niche mais également pour travailler
ce ce bah ce produit qui est qui est
aussi un produit du terroir de la région
la truffe noire donc il y a également un
jean à la truffe noire pour les goûter
c'est vrai que on est assez présent dans
la plupart des restaurants
gastronomiques de Poitiers des alentours
dans certains bars également euh
quelques points de revente mais
également bah sur notre site internet
léridupoitou.com on a une page marchande
et où tout simplement on peut aussi me
contacter via le site ou via Google et
procéder à des des visites à des
dégustations ça ça se fait tout à fait
bah disons que oui j'ai toujours plus ou
moins aimé ce ce ce domaine là et et oui
il y a une part de chimie qui est très
importante puisque Ben le principe de la
distillation c'est un c'est un principe
chimique tout simplement de séparation
des des éléments par
évaporation tout en utilisant ces
éléments pour bah fixer les arômes
de de ce que l'on va soit y associer
pour faire du jeans soit on va
travailler par un par un brassage pour
faire du whisky et et puis après tout
simplement c'est la passion aussi quand
on quand on a déjà une quand on a une
base d'idée et
que on cherche à le développer et qu'on
fait ça avec
passion tout avance et n'oubliez pas je
suis à de P chez
[Musique]
vous